on va passer au débat de ce club
maintenant consacrée au nucléaire
emmanuel macron a donc présenté hier son
plan france 2030 30 milliards d'euros
seront investis dans l'innovation et
parmi les thèmes abordés et les
investissements se sur le nucléaire un
milliard sera consacré au nucléaire dans
les années à venir on regarde ce sujet
de farah sauvage
à six mois de la présidentielle le
nucléaire revient au centre du débat
lors de la présentation à l'elysée de
son plan d'investissement pour la france
emmanuel macron a annoncé son objectif
d'un milliard d'euros pour ce secteur
d'ici à 2030 selon le chef de l'état le
nucléaire doit occuper un rôle essentiel
pour atteindre la neutralité carbone en
2050 objectif numéro un c'est faire
émerger en france d'ici 2030 des
réacteurs nucléaires de petite taille
innovant avec une meilleure gestion des
déchets pour produire de l'énergie en
particulier l'électricité nous avons une
chance et notre modèle historique
c'est ce qui nous permet d'être le pays
en europe
qui est parmi ceux qui émettent le moins
deux tonnes par co2 par électricité
produite c'est petit réacteur modulaire
nouvelle génération appelée aussi smr
d'une puissance de 70 mégawatts par
réacteurs viendraient en appoint des
centrales classiques mais à ce stade ces
mini centrale n'existe que sur le papier
ce qui questionne les écologistes qu'on
parle de 2030 mais ces mini centrale si
un jour elle voit le jour c'est pas
avant 2035 2040 la technologie n'existe
pas
alors je ne sais pas très bien
si c'est bien responsable de faire
reposer l'avenir de notre pays sur une
technologie qui n'existe pas à l'heure
où l'avenir des gros réacteur de
nouvelle génération est en suspens le
chef de l'état veut miser sur ces mini
réacteur jugés plus sûrs et plus faciles
à installer à l'heure actuelle seul un
avant-projet de petits réacteurs
nucléaires baptisée new world est en
cours de développement en france
arnaud est ce que quand vous avez
entendu et emmanuel macron hier vous
aime dit il a changé de philosophie sur
le nucléaire ou pas alors je dirais
qu'il a choisi une posture parce que
j'aimais de macron quand on s'intéresse
un peu aux questions nucléaires
on sait qu'il a toujours été assez
favorable au nucléaire avant d'être
présent de la république il était allé
faire des visites au creusot à l'époque
où le creusot savez c'est là où on a
fabriqué les pièces à de flamanville
tiens un tas de problèmes c'était un des
ministres qui étaient allés visiter le
creusot mais c'est vrai que depuis fin
au moment de son élection le choix
nicolas hulot a évidemment à
l'environnement qui était qui avaient
des positions assez lente il est clair
le choix de poursuivre la fermeture de
fessenheim qui avait été entamé par le
quinquennat précédent montrait qu' il
était un peu flou il arrondit l'on
disait qu'il avait le nucléaire on te un
peu et là c'est vrai que c'est assez
récent c'est un changement de la cud
deux cas passé récent à la faveur
effectivement de la présidentielle à la
faveur aussi du fait probablement xavier
bertrand qui est son principal sa
principale terreur on pourrait dire
électorale lui est très très très très
pros du clair très décomplexée soir on
va en parler puisque effectivement le
nucléaire s'invite dans la campagne et
la changer de posture emmanuel macron
sur l'éclair table à gernot oui il ay là
je dirais il ya deux choses aussi à la
crise énergétique qui fait que le
nucléaire fait changer de discours à pas
mal de gens d'ailleurs 1
et alors on la sait pas bien ce que je
disais un peu comme pour le tgv c'est
quoi les français comprennent plus parce
qu'on leur dit il faut passer de 75% de
production d'électricité issue du
nucléaire à 50% et puis là maintenant on
leur dit on va construire des
minicentrales donc comprend plus grand
chose moi ce qui m'étonne pourparlers
sur le fond c'est le milliard qui
consacrait ça me paraît dérisoire si
vous voulez quand on sait ce que goûte
une centrale et quand on voit ce que va
nous coûter parce qu'on sait même pas
encore combien ça a coûté le père de
flamanville qui était quand même un
chantier qui pot qui devrait être un
débat mais national sur lequel on
devrait avoir des interrogations
majeures ça fait quand même des années
et des années que ce chantier devrait
être livré il est toujours pas livré là
l'addition et la facture ce sale si je
puis dire d'année en année et personne
ne dit rien ou alors bon bah et c'est
quand même un choix décisif pour la
france est stratégique pour la france
donc ce milliard d'unités ça me paraît
tellement dérisoire que on a du mal à y
croire alors que ce que j'aimerais moi
et je pense que là dessus
la représentation nationale devrait être
beaucoup plus exigeantes il faudrait une
espèce d'audit de notre parc nucléaire
français savoir ces centrales qui ont
pour beaucoup d'entre elles plus de 40
ans comment on les on en augmente je
dirais la production
où la productivité dans les années à
venir et ce qu'elle comment on va on les
restaure comment on les entretient on
sait rien tout ça et on sait pas on
dirait nucléaire coûte pas cher
évidemment c'est une énergie qui coûte
semble-t-il moins cher que les autres
d'énergie les énergies fossiles mais en
entretien ça coûte quelque chose et on
n'en sait rien on nous dit rien s'il ya
vraiment un black out total sur notre
parc nucléaire français 1 voir nos
peut-être sur l'audit après on va parler
du couple alors l'audit balaya
effectivement et l'autorité de sûreté
nucléaire qui existe et qui existent et
qui fait qui fait travailler là qui
propose effectivement ce qu'on appelle
un grand carénage c'est-à-dire un
rafraîchissement des centrales si on
veut les faire durer près de 40 ans on
sait une chose c'est que c'est très cher
en revanche là où je suis d'accord avec
les frères c'est qu'effectivement ce
qu'on ne sait pas dans le nucléaire
parce qu'on dit toujours le nucléaire
c'est une actrice n'est pas chez accepta
le coût du démantèlement rhône alpes se
moque une ville parce que précisément
n'a jamais fait des vrais démantèlement
de vrais centrale on a fait des petits
démantèlement entre guillemets de
centrales ap l'ancienne et puis le coût
de l'enfouissement des déchets parce que
ça ça pour le coup c'est une c'est une
donnée absolument inexorable il ya un
moment et une énergie à l'énergie
nucléaire aujourd'hui produit des
déchets il faut les enterrer il faut les
traiter il faut il faut en faire quelque
chose et ce coup là effectivement on se
berce un peu d'illusions aussi sur le
nucléaire là dessus en disant nucléaire
c'est l'électricité qui nous a permis
d'être pas cher on ne voit pas
l'intégralité de l'addition quoi ça veut
dire que ce raisonnement du nucléaire
énergie abordable c'est un raisonnement
qui est un peu court termiste c'est ça
que le pari sur l'avenir n'est pas le
bon très honnêtement edf a été très très
entendre la propagande on ne peut pas le
dire autrement un peu voilà c'est fait
on était face à une institution pareils
d'éthique qui était très puissante est
effectivement temps que les centrales
étaient encore jeunes entre guillemets
n'arrive pas à expiration que l'idée des
déchets nucléaires à enterrer 80 mille
tonnes de déchets donc les réenterrer
quand même prendre un million d'années
pendant que toutes ces idées là était
dans les années 70 80 90 elle n'existait
pas parce que c'était une échéance à
venir donc beaucoup c'était pas cher
maintenant on commence à voir le bout du
tunnel si je puis dire est là on voit un
peu que à bure ça va coûter sais pas
combien ça va coûter à vrai dire qu'est
ce que dit le chef de l'état ce corps
n'est pas ce qu'il a déjà dit nucléaire
est une chance pour la france c'est
peut-être pas forcément ça nous remet à
tourner en plus je suis pas du tout un
spécialiste mais je peux ingénieurs jeu
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que on n'a
jamais fait vraiment une opération
vérité sur sur l'entretien sur
l'enfouissement des déchets tout ça
c'est quand même il ya une espèce
d'omerta
je suis pas persuadé que l'opinion
publique soit très avertis là dessus
on va on va continuer on va aller voir
le maire de fessenheim dont quelques-uns
sont mêlés en avons parlé du coup c'est
effectivement un argument
le prix de l'énergie cette énergie
abordable il ya une inquiétude aussi
c'est sur la dangerosité du nucléaire
est ce que c'est une industrie
dangereuse est ce que en matière de
sûreté des centrales c'est dangereux en
matière de sécurité elle si j'aimerais
vous dire non pas dangereuse
malheureusement j'ai un petit peu
inquiété alors pas sur la sûreté alors
faut faire la différence trop sûr car la
sûreté c'est la qualité des pièces à
résister à une surchauffe par exemple et
la sécurité c'est au cas d'attentât
terroriste par exemple moi j'ai pas
enquêté sur la sûreté l'asn sont s'en
charge très bien en revanche bien aussi
enquêter sur la sécurité pour loeb et
effectivement c'est préoccupant c'est
préoccupant parce que ce sont des
centrales qui n'ont pas été prévus pour
les nouveau genre de terrorisme qui
existent alors l'état nous dit que bien
sûr tout à fait ils sont ils ont pris
tout ça en contre là aussi on est dans
la grande muette donc on est obligé de
les croire sur parole malheureusement
oui le nucléaire c'était il ya dix ans
fukushima il n'y a pas si longtemps et
dans un pays le japon où je n'obtienne
pas connu pour une particule en exigeant
un et là c'était pas un fan de sécurité
sept ans de sûreté pour le coup c'est à
dire que à cause de l'inondation du
tsunami d'une surchauffe et la centrale
n'a pas résisté donc oui le le nucléaire
a le vent en poupe en ce moment et c'est
comme ça c'est un c'est un fait
intéressant à noter on ne peut pas
oublier malheureusement les deux effets
du nucléaire incontestable c'est que la
dangerosité possible du nucléaire même
si a jamais eu d'accident majeur en
france s'il y avait un accident majeur
en france a été calculée par l'irsn se
seraient 400 milliards d'euros voilà
c'est à 20% du pib france crif on parle
de l'accident majeur sans parler de la
possible évacuation de paris peut-être
de berlin peut-être de londres là c'est
pas les écolos qui disent un celi arts
et scènes donc à côté ce qu'on avait
quelques la bande il se serait ce serait
quasiment dérisoire payet à côté de ceux
d'un vrai accident nucléaire important
donc malheureusement on peut pas évacuer
ça et puis on peut pas évacuer la
question des déchets non plus
parler de ce sujet évidemment on va
aller à fessenheim me retrouvais le
maire claude brender bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous monsieur le
maire emmanuel
a donné le coup de grâce à la centrale
de fessenheim il y a quelques mois hier
il annonce que des mini centrales seront
construites
comment vous avez entendu ce discours
vous hier qu'est ce que vous avez
ressenti
écoutez déjà bonjour
j'aurais tendance à dire alléluia ça
fait mais ça fait j'aurais préféré avoir
cette réaction il ya cinq ans de fermer
fessenheim qui a été fermée de manière
dogmatique et uniquement sur une
décision politique donc donc donc
aujourd'hui un revirement claire du
président donc c'est tant mieux parce
que bon le il y aura pas de futur sans
nucléaire
quoi qu'on en dise même si c'est pas
l'énergie parfaite pour autant c'est la
seule qui c'est la seule qui aujourd'hui
est pilotable et donne une sécurité sur
l'approvisionnement électrique ce qui
est pas le cas des deux du renouvelable
donc le nucléaire sera absolument
incontournable et je pense
qu'effectivement dans les années qui
viennent cela il pourra continuer à
jouer un rôle dans la production
électrique en france et quel rôle du con
bah écoutez on parle de sfr donc les
gendarmes et un démonstrateur il faudra
bien s'y pilote fait ça m'a été le pab
le premier palier 900 en eau pressurisée
donc on peut imaginer des trades être le
démonstrateur d'aidé du futur nucléaire
donc le plus sûr et plus - mac os 10 en
moins de déchets
et guy également sécurité électrique
pour le procès de vallée rhénane pour
l'honneur et donc et qui en aura besoin
parce que l'allemagne sortant du
nucléaire et voulant sortir du charbon
également d'ici 2035 donc il y aura une
semaine et une une insécurité électrique
certaines salles étaient vous êtes
candidat vous accueillir ces mini
centrale ou en tout cas la technologie
qui va devoir aller avec
bah écoutez je pense qu'effectivement on
sera candidat sera aussi de cordoue
justin rose pour revenir à ma première
question quand vous entendez hier le
chef de l'état dit herbert on va
remettre un milliard dans l'énergie
nucléaire on va construire des
minicentrales est ce que vous avez eu
l'impression vous d'être un peu une
forme de caution politique à un moment
du quinquennat est ce que vous avez
ressenti une certaine amertume après la
fermeture de votre centrale vous
c'est également ce qui domine ici c'est
la colère parce que bon c'est de cette
fermeture elle est purement idéologique
et donc c'est nous sommes les dindons de
la farce quoi donc quelque part et en
plus on nous laisse en rase campagne
il faut dire que le le service
après-vente de la fermeture et est loin
d'être à la hauteur des enjeux de ce
territoire et et on doit se battre ou
sur tous les sujets donc donc on est un
peu les laissés-pour-compte mais
clermont mais même un peu beaucoup mais
qu'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui à
fessenheim déjà qu'est ce que la porte
et la centrale à fessenheim et
aujourd'hui vous dit on et les
laissés-pour-compte ya pas de service
après-vente ça veut dire qu'il se passe
quoi aujourd'hui dans votre commune
écoutez voilà si on
implante un projet de territoire mais
qui reste que dd d une lettre d'un des
lettres d'intention donc les choses qui
vont venir dans quelques années alors
que les emplois on les a perdus là
on est en train de perdre et donc là il
ya des parts d'un joint hier donc il ya
une dévitalisation de la commune qui est
à craindre bon heureusement et quelques
indicateurs quand même qui laisse penser
que ça va ça va plutôt bien se passer
maintenant le service après vente c'est
l'aspect fiscal et il ya quand même des
répercussions de cette centrale cet
emprunt c'est un le poumon économique de
tout un bassin de vie donc et
aujourd'hui on nous enlève serait ce
pour moins économique sens sans aucune
contrepartie système dégressivité de la
perte se quelques années
mais c'est pas suffisant c'est pas à la
hauteur ces territoires il va souffrir
énormément aussi rien n'est fait merci
beaucoup merci monsieur le maire d'avoir
été avec ce matin maire de fès avec
cliff des propos très clairs on a un peu
l'impression d'avoir été entendus la
farce à dire de façon c'est normal
attendait merde c'était évidemment une
source de revenus une source d'emplois
important pour lui et on peut accuser
effectivement emmanuel macron mais faut
pas oublier quand même que l'engagement
avait été pris par son prédécesseur sous
la menace d'ailleurs enfin pas la menace
mais sous la pression des écologistes
faut c'est une longue histoire c'est
cette cette affaire de fessenheim parce
que en fait c'est martine aubry qui
scelle à un accord
avec les europe ecologie les verts et
aux termes de cet accord bon il ya un
engagement sur fessenheim et qui est
repris par françois hollande qui
finalement est le candidat socialiste à
l'élection présidentielle
lequel accord et est pas mise en oeuvre
d'ailleurs par par françois hollande
c'est emmanuel macron qui le met en
oeuvre bon fessenheim et et fermés ça a
des conséquences évidemment importante
pour le site pour l'emploi sur place le
parti communiste il faut pas l'oublier
avec la cgt s'oppose à cette fermeture
est monsieur roussel qui est candidat à
l'élection présidentielle
aujourd'hui et et pro nucléaire il faut
le dire dans une gauche que plutôt anti
nucléaire donc voilà c'est tout un
contest et c'est vrai que la france les
français aspiraient sans doute avoir
davantage de lisibilité sur la politique
qui est conduite en france parce que il
ya il ya six mois le nucléaire était
achetée enfin il fallait réduire sa part
et maintenant on nous parle de
construire des minicentrales bien sûr
sur l'aspect politique mais sur ces mini
centrale arnaud il est promis d'ici 2030
ces technologies pourquoi ne peut qu on
connaît pas les tris pas du tout est-ce
que du coup c'est crédible de construire
des centrales d'ici la mi course à moi
je ne peux pas savoir ce que ce qu'on
sera faire d'ici 2035 évidemment ce
qu'on peut dire c'est qu'effectivement
ce qui est un peu paradoxal c'est que la
france qui avait un savoir-faire
énergétique enfin nucléaire
incontestable de fait puisque 70 % de
notre électricité vient du nucléaire sur
le sur les petites les minicentrales les
smr allez plutôt en retard par rapport
notamment aux états unis à la chine et
même en à la russie bon d'ici 2035 ça
fait c'est très loin de 1035 on peut pas
du tout savoir mais peut-être qu'il faut
préciser aussi c'est que c'est surtout
un produit la mini centrale qui est
destinée à l'exportation c'est à dire
que on peut pas comparer un a failli me
centrale c'est cinq fois moins puissant
qu'un opère voyez donc on peut pas
comparer par exemple la fermeture de
fessenheim dont je rappelle pourquoi
elle a été fermée aussi c'est parce que
c'était aussi elle est arrivée à
expiration et c'était la plus vétuste
est la plus dangereuse des centrales
françaises faut pas quand on dit que
c'est politique c'est toujours politique
ans et nucléaire mais avait quand même
une réalité rationnelle de fermer
fessenheim et il ya douze réacteurs qui
doivent encore fermé ailleurs je le
précise ça c'est dans le progrès mal
dans le projet macro
par ailleurs la réduction du mix
énergétique à 50% d'ici 2035 c'est
toujours au programme il faudrait pas
l'oublier donc je pense qu'il faut
surtout que les gens ne pensent pas que
les mini centrales vont remplacer les
grosses centrales des minicentrales
c'est un projet qui peut être
effectivement intéressant si on veut
d'un point de vue industriel enfin ça
sera surtout à l'exportation pour des
pays qui n'ont pas vraiment de ces deux
systèmes électriques aussi solides que
ceux qu'on trouve en europe en europe
c'est pas c'est vraiment des centrales
d'appoint
dans la campagne présidentielle
positions effectivement le nucléaire
s'invite dans la campagne et c'est même
quasiment un retour en grâce avec des
pros beaucoup de pro nucléaire et
quelques quelques anti je suis anti
nucléaire parce qu'un réacteur ça peut
nous péter à la figure rappelons-nous
fukushima cette phrase on la doit à
l'écologiste yannick jadot ce dernier
souhaite sortir du nucléaire de façon
progressive en 20 ans déployer les
énergies renouvelables pour lui moins
cher que le nucléaire est tout autant
créatrice d'emplois ce rejet du
nucléaire est aussi partagé par jean-luc
mélenchon le candidat de la france
insoumise veut même aller plus vite que
les écologistes sortir du nucléaire
d'ici à 2030 et fermer certaines
centrales vieillissantes qui font peser
un risque sur le pays il veut favoriser
des appareils de production énergétique
inoffensif telles que l'hydroélectricité
ou la géothermie on écoute nous devons
sortir du nucléaire quatre centrales sur
dix n'ont pas pu fonctionner cette année
à cause des sécheresses et des trop
grandes chaleurs les dangers qui sont
contenus personne ne sait les maîtriser
à cette étape c'est la raison pour
laquelle il faut déployer d'autres
moyens ça c'est pour les anti nucléaires
mais vous mehdi marion les
pro-nucléaires ils sont plus longs oui
et on en trouve même à gauche vous le
disiez avec le communiste fabien roussel
ou encore l'ancien ministre socialiste
arnaud montebourg qui assument leur
attachement au nucléaire et leurs
arguments sont partagées par les
candidats de droite le nucléaire est
l'énergie la plus performante au vu de
nos besoins la plus décarbonés ce qui
permet de tenir les engagements en
matière de réduction de gaz à effet de
serre et enfin c'est une garantie de
souveraineté et d'indépendance
énergétique
marine le pen veut en faire une priorité
nationale et s'engage à construire dès
son arrivée au pouvoir trois nouveaux
apn quant aux républicains ils ont
toujours défendu le modèle nucléaire
français et les candidats à
l'investiture appellent à une relance du
nucléaire et à la construction là aussi
deux nouveaux réacteurs repères écoutez
à ce sujet michel barnier moi je ne suis
pas partisan du tout nucléaire mais je
pense qu'on a besoin d'énergie nucléaire
et ça a été la grande force de notre
pays oui je réinvestis tout de suite et
je relance la construction de deux
couples de six réacteurs dont nous avons
besoin pour cette autonomie alors on
avait
commencé par emmanuel exactement le
président de la république estime qu'il
faut pousser le développement des
éoliennes on le voit bien actuellement
avec la mobilisation de barbara pompiers
mais en même temps le nucléaire doit
rester un pilier énergétique vous l'avez
dit un milliard d'euros seront investis
d'ici à 2030 pour développer de petits
réacteurs ce en même temps c'est aussi
la position du parti socialiste qui veut
développer les énergies renouvelables
mais qui dit également et je cite
olivier faur le premier secrétaire du ps
tant que nous ne sommes pas arrivés à
maturité sur le renouvelable il faut
maintenir un parc nucléaire non merci
marion
on voit le débat s'invite dans la
campagne arnaud vous me disais tout à
l'heure le discours d' emmanuel macron
yari lui permet de se positionner un peu
entre xavier bertrand louis et entre les
verts il permet aussi de toucher un
électorat particulier il lui permet de
toucher un électorat qui est plutôt
favorable à la poursuite du nucléaire et
qui est donc on doit les sondages c'est
un lectorat plutôt âgées effectivement
les jeunes sont plutôt hostiles au style
authority fonds va dire au nucléaire
alors que lecteur un peu plus âgé grosso
modo les français sont compétentes de
ayala moitié soit assez favorable au
nucléaire et l'autre moitié est plutôt
défavorable et c'est vrai que les plus
âgés sont sont plus favorables moi je
trouve que la phrase de michel barnier
ça a été une grande joie a été la force
de la france c'est bien le résultat
c'était quand on a un certain âge on
retrouvait les trente glorieuses qu'est
ce que c'était formidable et savants
atomistes français voilà le problème
c'est que l'on parle de l'avenir je suis
pas sûr que les grands un bon
malheureusement le br a quand même
démontré pour l'instant ses limites et
ses dysfonctionnements plus haut qu
autre chose alors effectivement sur la
position politique d' emmanuel macron il
est il est malin parce qu'elles sont
idée c'est de dire oui le nucléaire il
en faut un peu oui les énergies
renouvelables il en faut aussi c'est
très important il me disait tout à
l'heure 1 1 milliard pour nucléaire
s'est pas beaucoup les énergies
renouvelables dès aujourd'hui ces 6
milliards déjà versés déjà six fois plus
tard il ya besoin d'un déploiement
évidemment quelle sans commune mesure
parce qu'on en a appris plus tôt du
retard en france mais face aux verts qui
veulent sortir du nucléaire complètement
dans 20 ans qui se donne vingt ans pour
le faire c'est pas non plus immédiat et
puis face évidemment à la droite et
l'extrême droite qui sont totalement pro
nucléaire de manière presque caricatural
il joue un peu il joue un peu l'antre-2
quoi
qu'on puisse dire c'est que ça au moins
c'est un débat sain c'est un débat utile
c'est un débat nécessaire c'est un débat
c'est autre chose que de débattent
du sexe des anges et du prénom des
individus donc c'est moi je trouve que
c'est plutôt que si on pouvait faire
toute la vérité sur l'énergie nucléaire
en france savoir combien ça coûte ce
qu'il faut précisément faire pour
remettre nos centrales
d'aplomb parce que c'est vrai qu'elle
arrive pour beaucoup d'entre elles à
obsolescence tout ça ça me paraît tout à
fait
sans que cela soit au coeur d'une
campagne électorale c'est une campagne
électorale ça sert à ça aussi et je
trouve ça très bien
[Musique]